we see ourselves oftentimes as as doing
something beneficial whereas that's not
what is being perceived by whatever
species is doing their thing so the
first story that i'm going to
essentially tell you about is this this
story where there's extraterrestrial
beings who are considered part of the
universal immune system now if you have
a species that is behaving like a
bacterial infection then it gets
targeted by the immune system of the
universe at large at the same time as
you have an extraterrestrial being who's
like you know what there's so much value
in humanity we can make humanity choose
so even they are playing into this
choice point where you've got you know
these extraterrestrial beings who are
trying to prove that
the human race is essentially gone rogue
and as a clean up species meaning it's
what we have to take out of the picture
of the rest of the system because the
amount of collective asking from earth
planting the mineral kingdom animal
kingdom that are asking for us to go is
huge it's like a signal throughout the
universe